well the jets made some headlines
yesterday although the
the patriots uh uh commandeered the day
a couple of guys joining the jets day
one
big contracts receiver corey davis from
the titans a top
five pick four years ago no option
picked up in tennessee for davis
he becomes a member of the jets in
anticipation of whatever they do at
quarterback right they stand pat with
sam darnold or go after your guy zach
wilson
and then one of the top edge rushers in
a class that had
plenty of edge rushers plenty of them
did deals yesterday
carl lawson makes the jump from
cincinnati to new york on a deal that
pays 45 million over three years and the
sneaky jarrod davis signed
yeah watch for jared davis there was a
belief throughout the league that the
lions never used him right
he was a first round pick in 2017 19th
overall
one year seven million dollar deal he
and this is a strategic deal by him
and by the team they think this guy is
going to take off in robert salah's
defense so
the jets doing what they have to do to
lay the foundation for using that second
overall pick
and making their team better in saul's
first year as the head coach definitely
like i mean really the the team that i
look at with the second most impressive
day in free agency yesterday other than
new england
and they made sense as far as what it
does to their football team
you know first off like you talk about
corey davis michael lefour came from the
49ers
kendrick bourne was that guy for him now
they got corey davis he can run all
those routes and do
everything we kind of just talked about
you know with him up in new england
so that fits within what they're going
to do you know yeah enough speed to
scare you deep
but really awesome and everything else
too great route runner can go over the
middle
you know we saw him explode onto the
scene last year you know but a similar
stat line a little bit mike to the guy
like
nelson aguilar you're talking about too
got a little of everything
so that makes sense for the mike lafleur
shanahan system
you know got even a pat elf line for the
interior part of the o-line because
they're going to run the shanahan run
system so you need
good athletes there elf line can kind of
do that but then you talk about the
defense mike and
you know jared davis like you said he
was a guy i talked about on my podcast
last week as being that guy
where i went like he could be the guy
who signs for bigger money and everybody
goes wait what how who who is he what
how did that happen
yeah it was a one-year proven deal but
he's gonna be their fred warner
right or that that that bobby wagner
presence and he's a freak of nature he
was used the wrong way
up in detroit i mean he really is i
would be shocked if he doesn't thrive
in that in that system where he gets to
fly around and be like robert sala
and then they need their pass rusher we
know what the 49ers did with their pass
rushers and solid two years ago
and lawson like has had a little bit of
an injury history but man he's a rocket
he's a ball of muscle off the edge and
he can get after the quarterback so
good players system fit smart
buying by the jets and joe douglas to
start free agency it really was
best edge rusher they've had since john
abraham mohamed wilkerson had some sac
numbers from the interior position 2013
2015 double-digit years for him
but abraham the last guy from the
outside and get it done for the
jets right so it's it's a between that
and the possibility of getting a
franchise quarterback and zach wilson
the guy from byu that you thinks
that and this is this is not light
praise that you throw around when you
mention a guy like mahomes or rogers in
comparison to wilson but
the jets could be on the verge of
figuring things out in a way that they
haven't in a very long time
yeah so when you throw in where the
bills are and what they've accomplished
where the dolphins are and what they're
in the process of accomplishing
what the patriots are trying to do to
re-establish themselves
and the jets who are the stragglers
but are are hauling ass to catch up
right
afc east got a lot more interesting
yesterday it definitely did
you know you you i mean i of course i
look at new england just on paper
and i go okay yeah the bills are still
the number one team in the division but
i'm not putting new england too far
behind i'm not
you know and of course the dolphins
right there too now they didn't make a
ton of moves or do anything like that
yesterday they're kind of trying to
figure out their next moves it seems
like
but wow and yeah the jets are it seems
like on the right path hey we love the
head coach hiring
you know i think we're both believers in
joe douglas
and and what he can do there we'll see
how he does with all these picks in the
draft and the quarterback situation and
all that
but yeah on the up and up certainly but
you know if if i'm the bills of the
dolphins i perked up yesterday one yeah
the jets looked better but
ooh the patriots got some really good
players spent some money
and changed around their football team
too to where it's going to be a lot more
competition at the top of that division
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports